you
[Music]
you
hello hello everyone I'm Yvette
Rodriguez I'm a member of the Academy in
the public relations branch and I'd like
to welcome you to the Pacific Standard
Time la-la screening of Stand and
Deliver part of part of the Academy's
screening series that has been taking
place all fall I would like to thank the
Getty and Bank of America for sponsoring
this incredibly important program it
highlights our Latino films filmmakers
actors we thank you very much I don't
know if you're in the room but thank you
it's so important what you're doing you
just saw the trailer for alejandro
gonzalez in yatta - his first film I'm
gonna specialist and this Monday we will
be screening the film at the Academy in
Beverly Hills and tonight we're going to
be giving away free tickets to that
screening so on your way out if you
would like to see the film we have those
tickets and we also have a special
performance by Academy nominated
composer Gustavo Santo Santa Alijah I
always say that name Ron and actress
coyotl a though so come join us on
Monday and tonight I'm excited that we
have members of the cast and crew of
Stand and Deliver here so stick around
after the film and we will join you
afterwards for a panel discussion thank
you for being here
[Applause]
you
wasn't that great
I'd like to call the following down
tonight with us we have Tom Musca
mooskaa producer and co-writer edward
james olmos Lou Diamond Phillips
Tony Livingston Hicks casting director
Patrick Baca will go teh Carla Montana
Odeon Lydia Nicole Ingrid Oulu and
Danielle Vitale Ali okay well and in the
audience today we also have the composer
Craig Safin
[Applause]
what are you almost as well in the
audience I was at the end well we're
gonna start with Tom Tom can you please
let us know how this cain't how this
film came to be just if we can start
right there I was in UCLA film school
and I worked then we went tonight who
won the game I don't know who don't say
that I'm glad I was at the movie that
alright anyway I was in UCLA film school
and I was working with the gentleman who
is abroad and would be here if he could
his name is Otto I'm only Mendes we had
done a number that's here for a moment
and there's the director and we had done
a number of projects together students
and then this article popped up in the
LA Times and he said to me what do you
think I said well I think there's a
movie there and went over and saw mr.
Jaime Escalante who thought we were
going to do a little five-minute video
of him at the blackboard and then we
eventually sent a treatment to American
Playhouse and got them interested and
then Ramona and I took a probably the
best visit we ever took to a gentleman
on the other side of this thing they
made were James Olmos and we saw him he
was working in Miami Vice and we said
Eddie do you want to play Jaime
Escalante when you have a break you had
your shooting i'ma break in there in the
spring I think when we shoot this
February we shot in favor and Eddie said
mmm could be interesting
and we showed up at his house in Florida
and that was the beginning of moving
this thing forward and Eddie you had
heard of Jaime prior to this script
landing at your desk is that right yeah
I actually met him in June in they they
passed the examination in in May of 1983
in June of 1983 him and I were given by
the n-double-a-cp
I got the Humanitarian Award for the
year and he got Teacher of the Year and
then we were so happy to be together we
were standing up there we met each other
we were very happy we're celebrating and
then in August the report came back that
they were accused of cheating they had
gotten a lot of exposure before in May
and June the newspapers across the
country were giving them accolades that
were unbelievable because they had
outdone scores of even Stuyvesant and in
some of the biggest schools in in the
country and they had the highest scores
and so they were like the whole world
shook because it is only 3% of all the
students in the country seniors in the
country take that examination and only
3% of that 3% pass it it's a very
difficult exam and any of you that have
taken it you understand what I'm talking
about but at that time so when they went
they got them and accused them of
cheating
there was three times four times the
amount of press to sink them that was
just unbelievably difficult and and it
was so harsh on these kids that the
scene you know the scene where he goes
and talked to the ETS that was all
exactly what he said and what he did he
repeated exactly what went down that day
and it was so sad because they only gave
him one day to prepare and the test was
harder than any test given in advanced
placement at that time ever in this
country they really nailed him and you
saw the scores that came back and they
all passed was a miracle
credible well then one stop you met with
Eddie and then what was the next step
when did Lou Diamond getting the mix
here like what was the process Lou had
done la Bamba had been pick he was but
that movie had not come I believe Eddie
had not come out I yeah no I can I can I
give us a roll baby
so I done la Bamba I made scale on that
film like we all made on stand deliver
by the way and and I was out of money I
was out of money I was gonna have to
move back to Texas and in December of 86
I was yeah it was December of 86 I
landed a guest our spot on Miami Vice
and showed up in Miami in this wonderful
roll by the way the episode is called
red tape Viggo Mortensen plays my
partner who gets blown up in the first
five minutes and Annette Bening is the
girlfriend of the bad guy that's how hit
Miami Vice was in those days yeah no I
mean no serious man you know anybody on
their way up went through there and I
had one scene with Eddie and and he knew
that I had done la Bamba it was in the
can had done zoot suit with you know
Luis Valdez and Danny Valdez I couldn't
get a job in Hollywood cuz I was this
unknown kid from Texas playing a you
know obscure Mexican rock and roll star
you know with a negative pickup through
Columbia you know so I wasn't lighting
the world on fire and the movie wasn't
out yet and so Eddie and I did this
scene together and in his graciousness
literally after we finished the scene he
goes what are you doing next month
nothing man you wanna have lunch you
know any rights down in number he says
you call this number you call this
number when you get back to LA so I I
call the number and it's Ramon and Tom
and I go in and meet an audition and you
know I was I was the second person into
the cast so that's amazing
really the the X of pretties came by way
of Toni and her casting abilities she
did the entire casting of everybody else
you talk a little well the most
interesting thing about the show is that
Ramona and Tom came to us and they said
they would hire us if we were willing to
go into the barrio Wow
[Music]
yes so I said you mean the East LA
schools okay so we got that and of
course we're willing to go anywhere you
know so we did go and we tried to work
with kids in high school and now mind
you these are a lot of high schools with
no theatre program so these kids were
freaked out of their minds they didn't
know how to read a script they didn't
they you know they were too scared to do
anything so basically we went back to
school back to the office saying you
know there's a lot of Latino actors who
basically have been playing gang members
for most of their careers and let's give
them a shot you know at playing smart
kids so that's basically what we did we
called all the agents asked for all the
kids that were in this particular age
range we had Lou we knew what he looked
like we knew that we had to find the
youngest looking person so that they
could all kind of blend and you could
believe that they were sophomores in
high school which is a hard thing to do
so but it was a long process
they were very picky they we had a lot
of callbacks a lot of it was just look
see how they look together
look do they look like a class do they
look like they could hang out together
do they look like they like each other
they hate each other so it was a it was
a wonderful process it makes if the
casting directors delight actually
because you you're almost starting from
scratch and you're like creating you
know you're creating this team so it was
very enjoyable for me and I love them
and I can't believe they're all grown up
one of the things I'd like to say there
was one gentleman here that really saved
us there was a part of
his head man the finger man and it's
very difficult to cast because the
reality at that moment in time was very
very much very difficult we had not done
American me yet that was done in 91
this was done in 87 so to capture the
authenticity of the Valeo we needed
authentic an authentic gentleman to lead
the gang and Danny really either
considered it there
was in the room and he was our PA yeah
he was a production assistant we only
had to I think I don't think we could
afford anymore and he was there and he's
he's working and working we're
rehearsing and we had a young man he was
very good he ended up playing the young
man who originally was cast in the role
played my older son
my younger son was played by my son
Bodie almost is sitting out here Santa
Bodie say hello oh there he is
and in dire needs in the Latin my all my
principle films my family has always
helped me they've coming in taking on
the responsibilities of acting in the
movies and you know they're wonderful
and when Danny was standing there and I
was talking with Danny in between the
rehearsals and stuff and he was solid
solid from East LA I mean really
down-to-earth very saw the kid and I
said hey man can you help me man
and he goes surely on me Dillon I said
come over here for a second man and Tom
and Ramon I think they're wondering not
this let's just read this with us
remember that I was there man I know and
it gives me chills to think about and
the other thing that I want to point out
is up until this point like I said I'm
from Texas man you know I was a Navy kid
I didn't know what cholo from a churro
and freaking Danny took me on ride
around every day he would drive me
around East LA he'd show me the real
deal he'd show me the places we talked
we'd hang out you know and and he was my
research so too when this happened i I
couldn't been happier all of us we were
all very moved by it I remember when we
were rehearsing the scenes and we were
all in the room where kind of everybody
was scared because basically it was a
very difficult reality that we're trying
to hit and none of us had really worked
together and we were all extremely young
the directors first movie Tom's tom was
it that was your first film - that's
right the editor the DP
I mean we're first film everybody Oh get
a load of this I want to just say this
once and it's it's an accolade that I
must say that it made me cry when I
started to understand this moment in
time this film is the single most viewed
film in the history of film in the
United States of America bar none
there's not the you know I don't get
jaws et you know Godfather got it be
gone with the wind like 15 years ago you
know it's amazing accolade why because
teachers all over America use it every
year and millions of kids see it every
year most of you saw it in school no I
love the fact that I'm looking out here
and there there we made this film before
some of you were born and that's great
there's excellent there's a teacher here
could you stand up he saw when he was a
kid and he became a teacher yeah I often
applaud I often applaud teachers who
tell me laughing I use I used to film
every year been using it for 30 years
ever since I saw it and I said Wow
because I plot them because to have the
courage of showing this film in your
classroom and then after it's over you
get up and start to teach that's really
takes up a lot of courage yeah it takes
a lot of ganas that because it's it's
inspiring to the students but it really
really motivates the teacher and it
really makes the students also motivated
so anyway I thank you a many so it's
hard to believe that this film was shot
30 years ago is that right 30 years ago
how many days did you take to shoot this
do you remember 25 take 30 and what's
really super interesting about this film
as well is actually the budget the
original plan for the film it was going
to be it was going to run on PBS and
did and it did and then you went to Mill
Valley and then Warner Brothers they
bought it bought the film and release it
can can you just speak a little bit to
your experience I mean it's really
extraordinary right that those little
film like this had that kind of thank
you negotiated a window for the
theatrical release prior to the PBS
showing so we had they gave us I think
two years and Warner Brothers used it
put the film it still plays you know
like I said like any would say every
substitute teacher in the math class who
doesn't know how to teach math walks in
and just puts it on and then it it was
even featured in the movie bad teacher
it's amazing that some of the things
that happened on set Lou do you remember
the scene the one with your grandmother
where you're doing your homework to
remember that night that was a scene we
cut we ran out of time one day and then
we're at the end of the schedule and I
looked at Ramona and I said you know
we're moving pretty fast today why don't
we try that scene so I went out I didn't
know that yeah I went out in the streets
and I knocked on a door and found a
family and they were illegals and I said
do you you know we'll give you a few
hundred bucks if you let us come and
shoot a film in your place tonight and
we'll put you up in a motel so we hid
their place at about 11 o'clock at night
and you're there with your grandmother
the scene in your shooting and you
remember what happened no you don't so
what about about tucking in the shirt
what the suck in the shirt singer yeah
absolutely
so it's 1:30 in the morning and we're
all there and we're all exhausted and
all of a sudden we do a take and the
sound got ruined because there was some
noise we couldn't identify and it
happened twice and then I walked over to
the closet in that room and opened the
door in the entire family was sitting in
a closet and they had taken the money we
had given them to go to a motel and put
it in their pocket because they needed
the money and I thought somehow that
scene crystallized the type of people we
were making this film for they sat there
for four hours six members of a family
not saying a word not going to the
bathroom and you know that's the kind of
experiences we had during the making the
film I think we all knew if I'm not
mistaken out you answered we did we felt
we were making something specially we
didn't know what what amazing when once
seen the scene we had where I went to
her house right before the test we ended
up shooting time we shot that scene like
maybe I think 14 15 times because you
seen the background there playing a
baseball game and it Ramon yelled at me
because I didn't have enough extra so I
went out and started playing so every
time they were shooting if somebody was
getting her and an ambulance was going
by and then the car died yeah the car
didn't have remember Eddie the car
didn't have seats we were actually
sitting on buckets and it was a and it
was a screwdriver that he was shifting
with it was four o'clock in the morning
when we were doing the kissing scene and
we had the director in her crotch my
favorite really quick my favorite
speaking of Ramon Latino film obviously
we're and bye bye at this time except
for Eddie we're all unknown Alabama's
not out yet they actually the cops had
to escort me to and from sex as I was
wearing the wrong colors for certain
neighborhoods you know so yeah yeah god
knows what could've gone wrong there but
Ramon and and Tom you know these guys
have such a level of taste such a level
of artistry but you know we're a young
cast its a Latino movie you know and
we're all so freaking emotional that
every single one of us probably cried
every other take and Ramon used to come
in in his Cuban accident oh you're
milking it you're milking it and we did
it so often that he stopped even saying
that he would just come in and glare at
us and go
and then go like this with his glasses
I remember once I'll tell you a quickly
I it was my first film and I wasn't
really good at memorizing a lot so I
would I would tape my lines on people's
backs he was shooting and it was a
close-up and he called me like look done
and he stopped he said what are you
doing and then he looked down he goes
have you been doing that a lot I said
yeah he goes good for you so Lydia and
Karla what what do you did when you were
making the film did you know that that
it would be so special where did you
experience that well I knew it was gonna
be an Oscar contender when I read the
script when I read the script I said
this is Oscar this is it I had never
read anything so good not for us I mean
I've read stuff for class but not as an
actor you know was it was pretty amazing
it was and to see Eddie transform every
morning he would sit in the chair two to
three hours to get that look oh four and
a half to get that look it was it was
very impressive four and a half hours to
put it on and now and I have to take it
off every day yeah I mean same here I I
knew right away that it was I actually
remembered an article in the LA Times
with you and Ramon and then I had an
audition like shortly afterwards so you
auditioned for Ana do you remember that
I did I had that role and more I looked
at he says that's not Ana you were I was
shocked I was like I mean I could play
the smart you know girl but yeah I mean
just it was such an amazing experience
just that the I I had never gotten a
rehearsal time like we did we really got
to know each other and you know our
chemistry just worked and and just I
mean like Eddie was just like you know
master class for us all we were all
fairly
Green all of us have not completely
green if I could jump in from they like
I said it was my first film but I I read
for it once and then I would go in and
the Tom and Ramon would stare at me in
the room and of course I'm the only one
that had well as far as I know I didn't
have any acting experience but I knew
that I the film was kind of a sign for
me because I had actually been accused
of cheating in the test for culinary
serve America I'm a chef and when I
applied for the test I scored really
high and they accused me of cheating and
I had to take the test again and one of
my teachers in Jersey drove me up to the
Culinary Institute in Hyde Park New York
and and I had to retest and I tested
again and I scored higher but I
financially I couldn't go that's when I
joined the military and came out here
and it's been great ever since but that
was kind of my sign on how I knew I was
gonna you know it was kind of weird that
I got involved in the film and I said I
can do this
most people really the one thing that
they really want to know is what
happened to the students I'm doing
that's really the biggest question and
could you guys talk what happened to
your students I know I'm here your your
your student his the man he was
portraying the young man he was
portraying ended up being a little
lieutenant colonel in the Air Force he
was a jet fighter pilot that's where he
ended up but do you guys know what
happened I know that I believe I'm not
sure about the timing I think that oh I
that the timing was that her real life
character and my real life character
passed away within I think a week or two
of each other we what we did was we
created we interviewed about five years
worth of students and then we created a
lot of composites to make an ensemble
work Heimat told me through your martin
thought it might mean when he saw me in
the classroom I've seen when I was doing
yeah yeah yeah
and some of it like with loose character
those part of the conversation with Tom
and Ramon when we would go over the
right
because that was like my story when I
was a kid it was me and my grandma and
the whole thing about you know doing
math cuz I graduated with honors in math
when I was in junior high and when I
went to get my certificate I was so high
I don't remember any of it don't do that
at home folks don't do it at home kids
go to school don't do drugs you were
gonna say I have I have one little story
about the girl that played Anna
that was the one thing we had it we had
the movie advertised in one of the trade
papers and we were looking for these
kids and and I was desperate to find
somebody original and you know not an
actor so this little this girl who sent
me a letter with her high school picture
in it and that was Vanessa who played
Anna and she says in there that the
character that I described was her so I
said I have to bring her in because I
have first of all they have to see what
she looked like a sophomore even though
she just graduated she was so young
looking I said they have to see how
young a high school student is so I
brought her in and I had her read the
material outside of my office and she
came in and she read it and ice and she
would would look at the paper read it
and then look up at me I said now can
you take this home can you reverse that
can you you know not look at me when
you're hating the life okay and then she
came back and sure enough she did
exactly that and she brought in to the
audition with Eddie and the director she
brought schoolbooks
she sat there and she had her paper in
her hand and she said I don't need this
okay and she she was Anna and and and he
she told me that mr. Olmo said he took
her hand and put it in his pocket he
said you I will take care of you
you just listen to what I say so the
real Anna worked in our family she was
comin and babysit the kids and she was
going to college and when she graduated
from college she went on to become a
very high executive in the pennzoil she
became an engineer and she was very
smart and I was very very smart I need
that the other story that I heard which
I loved was that Vanessa on her first
audition had to catch three buses yeah
three buses from where she was working
at Burger King in East LA to get to the
audition in Hollywood she was yeah
exactly
yeah the second time when she came back
for the callbacks she said I can I have
to figure out how to get here on time I
said well how far do you live she told
me I was oh my gosh are you do you drive
she goes no I have to take buses then
you came from Montebello which is a way
out the heli out way out there
east of East LA way way up like George
Lopez would say like over there
and when I called her to tell her she
got the part it was the loudest screech
and the highest creature I had ever
heard in my whole life it was like oh so
loud but yeah yeah yeah I was working
with Tony on doing the casting that was
a PA and I was behind the camera taping
all the students like Ray came in raelia
stand up
[Music]
he's married the car light very good
cars we met at the audition for standard
yeah oh god oh god
so I was videotaping and all the the
actors that came in and when Vanessa
came in I was like all right and the
same with Patrick when Patrick came in
it was like all right forget it like
he's got the part no it took forever to
get this guy he helped me with my
audition but we went on to the alley
yeah he helped me come up with the one I
did that a lot good one I'm a good boy
this um when this film came out it was
very impactful not only because of the
subject matter you know to see a Latino
film on the big screen was very exciting
and but unfortunately here we are 30
years later two things come to mind
number one racism and discrimination is
alive and well thirty years later if not
more it's in the white house yeah and
and also here we are and we still don't
see films about our community and I
don't well maybe I know why but mr.
almost would you like to to elaborate
what do you think about where we are
today as a Latino community in Hollywood
and I know it's being pragmatic
I mean is it basically I'm not being
pessimistic I will be pragmatic we are
30 years ago we were less than 2% of the
images that you see on screen and on in
television and in theater today were
less than 4% but we were like 30 years
ago
we were like at 27 million people
Latinos in the United States of America
at that time and today were all work
we're past 60 million but they haven't
said it yet the last census they took
they put us at 55 million but we're well
over 60 million and we were well over 60
million in 2010 but now I think we're in
worse shape than we were 30 years ago
because there's so many more so much
more of us and we're still not part of
the understanding of storytelling
you just cannot tell stories using
people minorities you can't indigenous
people Asian Americans Latinos African
Americans are 12 percent of the
population and they are 17 percent of
the images that you see that's excellent
that's how they we should be at at least
at 15 15 15 15 you know with you know
say 25 percent non-ethnic you know
Caucasians should handle storytelling
like they have but that we should be
able to understand stories told by
indigenous people you know of Asian
people Asian American people their
stories just it's a story I mean the
reason that this hit us so hard and she
says those academy-award that we didn't
know whether it was gonna be whatever
not man it was like the furthest thing
from our heads I mean basically for me I
was just happy to tell this story and
that Jaime would allow me to go into his
house in his home I'll tell you one
story that's still to this moment
because he was an amazing human being
and it still makes me cry when I think
about him he was such a giving man I
went into his house and it was brought
about the day before we're gonna start
principal photography you know that his
was myself
fabiola his wife and myself and Jaime
and we're sitting at the table his
dining room table and I'd been there
many times and I just watching just
watching always observing in this
classroom I spent a lot of time with him
and he was sitting there and I asked him
I said I got one more question you know
and I turned to Fabiola and I said
what's the hardest truth you've had to
live with you know dealing with Jaime
and she looked at me without even
blinking and she says that he wants to
be buried with a picture of his children
and Jaime was the head was down like
this the table was here his hands were
underneath the table he was leaning
against it so his face was close to the
table and I saw the tears that were
running like water and hitting the table
and I realized that what she said was he
wanted the picture of his children with
him when he died not the picture of his
children and his family you wanted a
picture of his joy and she said and she
just proudly said it and it just
destroyed me I couldn't we couldn't even
use I told Tommen and Ramon about that I
said we can't use that we can't there's
just no way are we gonna go there
because that you know just like you
listen it was intense it was a beautiful
experience but it was very real and very
honest because I mean it was he didn't
miss one day of shooting it was every
day and I would get done as an Essene
and and he would be there watching me
doing the scene and be standing over
like this and then I'd be done with the
scene he'd go the scene that Eddie
alluded to earlier the Educational
Testing Service scene did happen it
happened a lot the way it's depicted but
when Jaime read the script he had a
major objection to the line we had
written when he said if I catch you on
the street I'm gonna be the shooter he
did not say that
and I said Jaime come to the set if you
don't want it won't be in the
okay and you remember and then we did
the scene and you did the same catch you
on the street if I can weigh in on that
other question too it's interesting
because at that time you know we had we
had la Bamba we had stand-in deliver out
north they salad whether it was a period
in time where all of a sudden everybody
was proclaiming that the Latin wave you
know in filmmaking had arrived that you
know we were we were going to see you
know Latinos take their place in the
pantheon of cinema and then it died it
went away it comes back every every few
years one of the reasons it comes back
is people like you know Henry James
Olmos right here that I also did Philly
Brown with you know they that you did
American me I mean Eddie tells stories
of culture tells stories of his
community and makes them Universal it
makes them American stories which is
what they are when he said the line you
were the true dreamers knowing what our
dreamers daca is going through right now
man I did just almost brought tears to
my eyes again it is so sad that this
movie is as relevant today as it was
then in in respect to where we are in
our race relations and in our politics
and in how we treat one another I've
been fortunate to represent a number of
those communities Asian American a
Native American because I'm a mutt I'm
an American you know and I've been
really honored to do that throughout my
career but what it takes and there's a
conversation going on in this country
now and maybe that is the silver lining
to all of this to this dark dark cloud
that is over us and that is we are
talking more we are galvanized we are
motivated we are out there in the
streets trying to make a difference we
realize that our voices still matter
that things that drove us and drove the
filmmakers to make a movie like this
still matter and they matter more than
ever and we have to do that but what we
need especially in the film community
I'm going to say that there are more
opportunities for Latino actors than
there were then there you're seeing a
few more on television you're seeing
other their specific casting there are
more Latino stars than there were then
you know and I think that's a very very
positive thing what we now need are more
Latinos right writers and directors and
producers and people telling those
stories saying no this is not a niche
story this is not just an arthouse story
this is a story that has universal
appeal and will appeal not only to all
of America but globally and to start
thinking in respect to that and that is
it is what we need and one of the things
that I spoke at NYU a few years after
this film came out and a young Puerto
Rican actress stood up tears in her eyes
and said I finally saw people who look
like me up on the screen and that's what
we need is we need to for you out there
and and those of you who are interested
in film and and what not to to
understand that it can be done that you
can be a first-time filmmaker a
first-time actor a first-time anything
but you can't get it done and that you
have to to get out there and apply
yourself and do it because many people
sitting up here have proved that it can
be done and that you have to now take
the reins and you have to to make your
voice heard and we need you we need you
more than we ever have
amen and I want to add to that
what we have today that we didn't have
30 years ago is we have cameras on your
phones we have computers we have a
tablet you can go make your movie
without having to get a big budget so
there's no excuse for us to do our own
projects today we're 30 years ago we
didn't really have that option that you
know you didn't go through the studio I
think this was probably one of the first
independent Latino films that came out
in the 80s because if it didn't come
through the the studios you didn't get
it made so you guys have that ability
right now you with that camera you with
that camera all of you can make your
little film there's a man who made a
film called tangerine that ended up in
getting nominated and he did it on his
iPhone so there's no no excuse I mean we
could talk about what we don't have what
we don't have but you now have it in
your hands so all you have to come up
with is a story that's compelling enough
that can go to the Oscars
we need more stand and delivers yes and
you can and you can start by looking at
history that's where you get information
you look at our history American history
and you will find them hidden figures
how many people knew there were black
women in the NASA program how many I was
a history major and the stories are
there they just need to come out and it
needs you know you need to just find
those little gems and and that's how
things like this get made not only that
I mean I know Danny's getting he's
prepping a film right now brother Jonas
I'm just wrote and directed a film shot
Oh Votto this summer and it's probably
one quarter of the price of Stand and
Deliver thirty years later because of
what Lydia is talking about the
gatekeepers are have shrunk back there
are cameras computers you can make the
same type of film we made there now for
1/4 of the price that we made that on
film so
you have the means of making movies and
you will be in your film to just ask
well come in your film we're available
they're all available and I don't see
Julie is there anything else that you
would like to share with this audience I
know that we have a short time for this
panel so if there's any parting words
I'd just like to say that to remember to
encourage your children encourage them
to have their own voice and to become
their own person
and I think that when you do that then
you then you'll be you really be
surprised as to what they can become and
who they really are instead of what you
think they should become because I think
that's a big problem in the Latino
community I'd like to just ask a favor
of all of the students that are here
from Bell Gardens and from Santa Ana
schools please stand up yeah take a good
look at these students okay take a good
look at them these students are all in
the youth cinema project yeah they are
all making their own films they're all
they started in grammar school through
junior high and through high school the
ascent of a project has now been going
now for well we started in 1998 but it
really took off about four years ago and
now we're in nineteen school districts
throughout the state of California and
over 2,000 children and if we look at
them now not all of them want to be
filmmakers some of them will some of
them we'll definitely move on in a way
that they've never been a the r-system
film system has never been ready for
because they're really getting an
advanced understanding of filmmaking
they're getting everything from the
conception of the story through
treatment through script through
production post
duction marketing distribution how to
build your LLC and by the time they're
out of high school they will it was a
funny thing because we now have a
pathway from Santa Ana Santa Ana it gets
ten students are gonna go from this
group they will go into Chapman
University with a full scholarship for
four years and each year over the next
four years each year Chapman will add on
another ten so within four years there
will be 40 students coming out of Santa
Ana where we're setting we're trying to
set up the same situation with UCLA and
SC and different schools but I'm so
proud of them because they're gonna show
you your films will be shown in made
this year correct you guys been ready
now how many of you sit down you guys
sorry out what they're gonna stand there
God how many of you is this your first
year in the program how many of you each
second year in the program how many have
been three years in the program how many
have been four years to the program okay
so you've got to realize that they
started in the fourth grade when you see
fourth graders you get the experience of
finding their voice it's amazing yeah it
brings solid tears of unbelievables to
the grown-ups ed what's the program the
entire AFI came ever the executive
director all of their all of the heads
of the school all the different
departments came and they were
experiencing it and they went and they
said Bob gizelle says dad this is the
most advanced understanding of teaching
I've seen in the 21st century and it's
nothing more than showing him how to
make a film the whole perspective we
took exactly what they're doing at AFI
and we stand we're giving it to them in
the fourth grade
it's like teach
you a language they teach you a language
in this country starting in the 10th
grade it's way too late you got to start
teaching the language in the first grade
second grade third grade when we started
teaching them how to use the language of
cinema and storytelling and
collaboration and communication and and
creative thinking critical thinking and
creativity those four the Common Core we
try to teach that through usage of
English they try to teach it in span
math they try to teach Common Core and
different science and they can't do it
not like you can do it when you teach
these kids how to sit around a table in
groups of six and they learn how to
produce it learn how to direct they
learn how to do the camera they learn
how to do the sound they learn how to do
the editing they learn it all they're
learning all the aspects of it and that
yeah some of them become first aid these
other than become I want to be the
director I want to produce it I want to
be the actor a lot of actors and boy
I'll tell you what they've learned is
creativity critical thinking
communication and collaboration but I
tend to get out of the fourth grade at
the highest level they come out like
kids that have come out of that this
program are way ahead of any kids that
are in their grade class and not that
they're smarter I'm not saying that
they're you know they're smarter kids no
they just have a sense of self-worth
self-esteem and self-respect that they
cannot get any other way so I'm very
proud that they're here tonight I hope
you guys realize that this is a very
different how many of you guys said
seeing the movie before raise your hands
that's good that's good I was gonna say
what's wrong with your teacher no no I
just know that this is happening and
there are over 2,000 kids in the program
right now so you know that next year we
this year from last year we augmented
300 percent we have the the directors of
Jenelle bode and Russ roughing all here
tonight he's not here yeah he is
Rafael's here Ralph I
l please stand bode against Annie's
these manager Janelle she's the she does
all of our curriculum and does all of
our classes where's Raphael Oh Sergio
Sergio is here with Raphael here no
these are the people who actually do the
intensive work of going throughout the
entire state making sure that everyone
is up to the standard because we have
what it is we have 32 I think we have 32
mentors right now coming out of AFI
coming out of NYU coming out of SC
coming out of UCLA coming out of the
different film schools throughout the
United States they come in for 90
minutes during the class during the
school class that after-school special
during the class right during the class
we break for after during English okay
90 minutes you're gonna make your films
their brains explode and then they go
back and they're willing to go back into
you know doing math doing science doing
they are dying to get home and continue
to work on their programs and and
they're greater the accident motivates
them throughout the entire school year
to a higher level and I got to tell you
I really applaud Bodie Janelle Sergio
Raphael because there are 32 mentors
that have given themselves to this
program 90 minutes twice a week for the
entire school year that's too much I'm
telling you
when Bob gazelle and hey if I came when
Bob is L&A if I came to the program
Bob gazelle said to me we want this
program we want we want we want to bring
this to the country I said you know I'm
on the board of trustees them okay if I
I said Bob you guys are the American
Film Institute this is coming the cinema
project is the Latino Film Institute the
Latino Film Institute has to bring this
to the American public we need people to
say oh Latinos brought this to our
children
Latinos helped us get to this level of
understanding thank you Latinos for
giving us this one point of entry into
the world that we didn't have before you
guys were there yeah I wouldn't give it
to them and that only wouldn't give it
to them they in turn they became one of
our sponsors so they're very they were
very good but it was really funny
because the head of the production house
came in and they were standing there and
he says to me he says man you're
teaching them what we teach our students
I said yeah but we're teaching in the
fourth grade
it's a lot different they're gonna gain
a lot more than they're gonna get you
know by the time you get into AFI you're
one of sixteen groups that are allowed
to be in there five for the first year
the second year you're only eight eight
groups work out their film so go from 16
to 8 and only eight graduate we had
stuff if I stuff but at the same time I
got to tell you these kids I love you
guys for doing this and you guys have
been given a great opportunity I'm
telling you right now Santana it was the
sponsoring group that school system that
school district was school district that
started us off four years ago they said
yeah we want you come on we watch over
here and so Santana was a first place
and then Bell Gardens in Montebello they
jumped in and they're both here and I'm
very proud that their and their teachers
other teachers here where the teachers
stand up man say hello now if you guys
should get your ticker Baus teachers
please
stand up yeah without you guys we have
absolutely nothing thank you guys so
much you know about about set what thank
you I want to thank everyone for being
here this evening and Eddie received an
Oscar nomination for his performance in
Stand and Deliver and we all owe him a
debt I mean Eddie thank you so much for
sharing that it's inspiring and you have
done so much for our community and I
just want to thank you and thank
everyone for being here but thanks Eddie
I mean that's an incredible present
thank you all for coming thank you thank
you folks thank you very much
[Music]
you